we tend to casually talk about American
companies or think of GE is an American
company or caterpillars an American
company and of course these companies
are headquartered in America they're
chartered their corporate charter is in
America but they're really global
companies and the CEOs of those
companies often are they're getting more
than half of their sales outside the US
often more than half their profits
outside the US
they have subsidiary companies or branch
companies around the world they have
other constituencies they have workers
in China or in Brazil or France or
wherever they have to treat those
workers fairly they have to deal with
the Chinese government and the and and
Brussels and Tokyo so in a way they're
almost quasi sovereign entities that
countries exactly but but they have
resources that far exceed those of most
countries and and so they're global
players and their allegiance is through
their shareholders but not necessarily
to any particular country and and I'm
not saying that it should be because as
I said the CEOs do have responsibilities
to a broad constituency but are we as
American citizens and particularly
officials in the US government tend to
think of them as American companies and
it says having some kind of special
Allegiance or special obligation to the
United States now and in talking about
globalization over the last 10 or 15
years we've had a kind of a mantra Bill
Clinton actually popularized them that
globalization will make everybody rich
and being rich they'll become Democrat
and being democratic they'll be peaceful
well it looks as if people can be rich
without being democratic alright without
having a rule of law and we thought that
the global corporation would be the
transmission belt of democratic values
into authoritarian societies but
ironically and perversely it seems that
the transmission could be the other way
the head of a global company in
Washington is a big player a big
political player that the CEO of a
global company makes big political
donations he or she has legions of
lawyers and lobbyists in the United
States with a rule of law companies can
challenge the government in court and
win they can stop the US government they
can cause legislation to be written
they can cause legislation to be blocked
or to be passed their big political
players in Beijing they're not in Riyadh
they're not in Singapore they're not
there supplicants they don't deal with a
rule of law in Beijing so they have to
be careful about the relationships they
have with officials they have to stay on
the right side they don't make political
donations they don't have they don't
challenge the governments in court and
so in a funny way the head of a global
company is more responsive to the wishes
and desires of the authoritarian regime
than of the democratic regime and so
what's beginning to happen is the
transmission of authoritarian values
into the u.s. regime and those global
corporations who frequently are on
government advisory committees so you
have this funny
the government thinks of American
companies and we have advisory
committees for the astrayed
representative and other officials and
the heads of these global corporations
come in to advise the American
negotiators but you wonder are they
thinking about the interests of America
or are they thinking about the interest
of their corporations
and in thinking about the interests of
their corporations to what extent are
they beholden to the desires of the
authoritarian regimes again I'm not
trying to be critical of the CEOs I
think they're in a very difficult
position and I think many of them
struggle I think many of them Jeffrey
Immelt of GE has voiced this he's talked
about GE being a global corporation and
yet understanding that maybe
shareholders are not the only obligation
maybe it has other obligations but it's
a difficult position for the CEO but my
main point is that in making policy for
the United States we need to clearly
understand the role of the global
corporation and right now we don't
well in conjunction with other countries
I'm not sure that's a good interesting
question actually maybe there should be
some kind of a global chartering
corporate chartering mechanism but for
ourselves I think that I would like to
have corporations chartered by with a
federal Charter rather than a state
charter and I would like to have a rule
in the u.s. like the Canadian rule in
Canada only natural persons can make
political donations I'd like to have
only natural persons making political
donations in the US and I would like to
see a revamping of the advisory
committees in the US government so that
there is a better mechanism for defining
and considering the American interest
rather than the corporate global
corporation interest